there's a million questions i can ask
here
like one you mentioned bj penn you uh
first of all you are undefeated in the
ufc and one of the fights
you've had is against bj penn which is a
kind of an incredible fight you you want
performance of the night
what did it feel like to uh
to face pj pen and to beat him
definitively as he did
like what's that whole experience like
i'll be honest i didn't know
if i was going to ever be able to to
fight again after beating gray maynard
in 2016.
um and i've had a couple of periods of
those i i was about to join the army
actually in uh
when i was 30 before the uh for the ufc
before
jen sent me over to ultimate fighter i
didn't want to go cause i was like one
they're never gonna pick me two i'd be
terrible for tv
three i'll probably say something i'm
gonna get you know burned to death in
the streets
you know i'm like this isn't a great
idea and then uh she said we'll go out
there see what happens
do it anyway you'll be you'll regret it
if you didn't and then i ended up doing
ultimate fighter and then
so i fought three times on the show and
then i fought um
for the for the finale so there's four
times in like
five or six months which was great and
then it took me a year to get another
opponent
um and that was gray maynard and then
gray was obviously a very tough guy
managed to get a good outcome there then
it took two years to to fight b.j penn
and that was you know obviously i'm
training all the time every single day
and that never stops but that was i'll
be honest like pretty deeply frustrating
because you know as
a human being as an athlete you know i
think as an athlete you die twice like
you have an athletic
peak or area and then then you go on
with the rest of your life
but it is a microcosm for the rest of
your life it's like you're seeing this
the sand tick away in the hourglass or
drop away and you're going man this is
these are the years between 31 32 33
like i'll
be at my best at this time my absolute
best physically now not technically i'm
a lot better
now than i was before and i planned but
at a certain point you will
unless you're bernard hopkins you will
reach diminishing returns and
i guess that's a long the long wait you
can feel the clock ticking is
frustrating so why why did it take two
years for bj
i uh i i that's the question people ask
a lot like
why does nobody want to fight right now
i don't know i probably they probably
think they'll get infected by whatever
this is but
i don't i don't i don't blame them but
uh i mean you're a really tough opponent
is the bottom line
i'll say that i'm different maybe they
perceive that the uh the the
the threat is greater than the reward
i'm hoping that now that we're ranked
number 12
you know in the ufc rankings that uh
that that will change and i know that if
we're
one more win and then we're in the top
ten that you know now
you're there but uh what i've
consistently found is that like randoms
want to fight and i'm like go away
you know i didn't come here for you you
know because if i wanted to just fight
anybody i could go down to a waffle
house and yell until like dmx shows up
and we can we can fight cause he'll be
at the waffle house too who am i kidding
i really want to hang out with the mx
but uh you know it's like you want to
when i had the opportunity
and dmx oh my god that was so cool i
would
never flick shows i would never fight
dmx we'd be on the same team no
but uh anyway um it's i i guess um
i i accepted fights against uh i asked
the guy to ask about llamas i said yes i
got asked about dennis bermudez i said
yes
um you know like long periods of time
and they at that time well you know in
between 2016 and 2018 um
i was struggling to have have opponents
who would sign up
and uh us i haven't turned down fights
i've just said hey
you know keep the i don't care about
fighting the randoms and it's
when you have a successful school you're
like you're
running you're martial artists broadly
speaking so it doesn't make sense to
to take fights that aren't like right
that fit
a certain kind of trajectory for your
career and that's when when bj penn they
said well bj's looking for an opponent i
was like
i'm your guy and uh and i think that you
know bj accepted that fight because
another jiu-jitsu guy i don't think he
perceived that i was much of a threat on
the feet
um and uh you know i was able to
it was neat to get it to compete against
someone
uh you know who's one of my heroes one
of the people i looked up to in mma for
the longest time are you intimidated by
that
no no i love competing i i don't really
get
nervous or scared before fights i'm not
afraid to get hurt and not afraid to win
i'm not afraid to lose it's
i i'm just excited for the i feel
thankful for the opportunity to compete
and the opportunity to
to play when it matters you know i i
just
but that's the only time i'm interested
in playing anymore is when it when it
matters when the opposition
is i know that you know it's funny
because people pick on on
a lot of some opponents particularly
after after the fact like if you
if you get a good outcome well then uh
of course lex beat that guy that guy
wasn't that good i'm like well i was
that's after the fact i get to say that
and also as the person in the ring you
know bj penn
has hurt a lot of people in in mixed
martial arts cage
and i could actually absolutely have
been on that list um
so it was neat to get to compete against
someone that i really respect someone
that i looked up to for a long time
someone
who has a great skill set and also i
went up and wait to fight him in his
weight class he didn't have to come down
to mine which is where he'd take lightly
it was lightweight yeah um i'm generally
a featherweight i walk around like 158
pounds
so um what's the lightweight
featherweight uh lightweight is
with a day before weigh-in and
featherweight is 145 with the day before
weigh-in so i'm a little bit more
properly sized for featherweight but um
anyway uh
you know i so i didn't feel like
obviously he was giving up
a couple years of age but i was giving
up size and all this other stuff
and it was you know i was just excited
to have the opportunity to step in
against someone like bj
and uh you know we managed to to get out
of there with a with a good outcome
without getting too banged up but uh
just it was cool because we tied up on
the fence
and just even uh the second you know is
when you're rolling with somebody and
you touch and you can feel what they're
doing you go oh man this guy's really
good um you can feel the calm you can
feel the small minor adjustments that
they're making the subtle things that
they're doing
and that was one of those things that
was really neat and gratifying because
you know you never know sometimes people
that you've heard of are a little bit
less technically proficient than you
thought and other times you'll meet some
guys you're training like who the hell
is this guy how have i not heard of this
person
and uh bj was exactly as a jiu jitsu guy
what i would have thought
and uh another thing that's another
thing that bugged me about how people
reacted after the fight
is uh you know basically going oh bj
screwed up this screwed up that i'm like
all right yeah it's so interesting
that's sad
i that was you know one of the and to me
i mean as a fan of both that was a
beautiful moment is uh
as a as a kind of passing of a torch in
a sense
of exceptional performance
you